m
thématique
connaissez-vous dame holle c'est une
figure très importante de la mythologie
germanique qui inspira aux frères grimm
l un de leurs nombreux comptes
on dit qu'elle vit dans les montagnes de
s et aujourd'hui encore les habitants de
cette région au centre de l'allemagne
reste très attaché à ce personnage
fabuleux
ils lui ont même dédié un sentier de
randonnée le sentier de dames rôle
on
notre voyage commence à battre car ce
sera fun
nous irons jusqu'à berck à talent au
pied du mont myners puis nous
cheminerons jusqu'à cinq clones soldes
plus de 150km au pays des contes de fée
bat car ça faisait une petite ville
d'auch fondée en 799 pour accueillir les
huguenots venus en nombre se réfugier en
allemagne
la plupart fuyez la france suite à la
révocation de l'édit de nantes qui
reconnaissait la liberté de culte aux
protestants ils sont venus avec leur
savoir-faire leur culture leur artisanat
marquant ainsi durablement la
physionomie de la ville
en témoigne la maison de vins rumeur
fondée par les descendants d'une famille
de vignerons huguenote
des vins du monde entier vieillissent
dans sa cave voûtée à l' architecture
typiquement française
aujourd'hui c'est dorothée rumeurs qui
perpétue la tradition familiale
porté par l'héritage de ses ancêtres
originaire des cévennes poursuivi pour
ses convictions religieuses le vigneron
isaac suchet de colt quitte la france en
783 et trouve en allemagne une seconde
patrie ce sera son petit fils ferdinand
qui parviendra à relancer la sphère
familiale en 1838 il acquiert une
parcelle de terrain et creuse une cave à
vins à flanc de montagne
cette histoire de roter rumeurs m
l'évoqué autour de dégustations lors de
concerts et d'expositions qu'elle
organise au sein de son établissement
et
outre le négoce de vins la maison
produit depuis 1900 tout un assortiment
de liqueur élaboré selon des recettes
familiales pour cette randonnée au pays
de dames relais nous nous sommes joints
à un groupe de randonneurs et découvrons
en leur compagnie cette première étape
gourmande de roter nous emmène dans
cette petite distillerie les liqueurs
doivent leur succès intemporels et
universels aux ingrédients naturels
qu'elle laisse aussi et à la richesse
des combinaisons aromatique du sucre de
l'eau de vie de vin ou de l'alcool
neutre et toute substance végétale
offertes par la nature mais elles sont
tout autant le fruit du talent des dix
touristes men gardien de recettes tenue
secrète transmise de génération en
génération
l'écurie de fass et d'arts orford est
une smart du contrat est de 16 g us de
roter fabrique également un bis ter une
liqueur digestive aux vertus presque
magique ni à gauche qui perd 6 médailles
or pas si elle se limite à aller voir il
n'en faut pas plus pour convaincre nos
randonneurs ils ne peuvent reprendre la
route sans une bouteille de biterre du
soling dans le sac à dos so fresh
transports
on est à présent direction le sud le
long de l'a 20 heures
la région montagneuse du weser bergland
et ses grandes forêts de sapins fürth
une véritable source d'inspiration pour
les frères grimm qui y ont collecté
leurs plus beaux contes
nous arrivons à un ovaire chemine dun
qu'on appelle plus simplement à london
elle est surnommée la ville des trois
rivières car elle est située au
confluent de lavéra de la foule da et de
la weser c'est ici que nous quittons la
vallée pour nous enfoncer dans la forêt
de cao phong heures
une étape plutôt sportive il ya tout de
même quelques mètres de dénivelé à
gravir et ça ça donne faim heureusement
voilà qu'arrive le ravitaillement
quel timing evelyne et ulrichen possède
l'une des meilleures charcuterie fine de
la région et il ne se lasse pas de faire
découvrir leurs spécialités de football
ait de quoi ravir les papilles de nos
randonneurs affamés place à la
dégustation
verdict il faut dire que les schumann
n'est pas un charcutier comme les autres
il a été adoubé chevalier par la
prestigieuse confrérie du goûte boudin
derrière ce nom évocateur se cache une
institution créée en 1963 en france dans
le perche qui organise chaque année le
concours international du meilleur
boudin
mais quand on goûte l'excellence de ses
produits a été maintes fois récompensé
des trophées qui figure en bonne place
dans le magasin
en mai 2010 il a même remporté une sorte
de prix nobel du goût décernés par
l'académie des confréries gastronomiques
honoris causa de l'académie de
gastronomie schönbrunn à schaffhouse
thoune normandie maine
ou liszt schumann dirige sa petite
entreprise avec sa femme evelyne
originaire d'alsace
cette dernière tient à présenter une
autre de leurs créations
si ce n'est plus président mais je crois
manier les gens pas ne va pas faire trop
fait du boudin au chocolat le mélange
est audacieux et peut laisser perplexe
mais encore une fois la charcuterie fine
schumann fait mouche
ce petit mais si elle se sauve à ce qui
chez lipp
outre volkswagen qui ont des choses qui
moralise espace cette petite pause
gourmande arca qu'est notre fine équipe
à présent en route pour la prochaine
étape de ce voyage en s le moma isner
avant d'aborder cette terre de légendes
nous décidons de faire un petit détour à
vicenza osm dans la pittoresque vallée
de lavéra nous y avons rendez vous avec
they have landes tehahe bio ingénieur en
agronomie
mais elle est aussi un peu sorcière une
bonne sorcière elle connaît les secrets
des plantes et leurs bienfaits et dans
son atelier elle fabrique toutes sortes
de gants et de pommade avec ce que lui
prodigue la nature son ingrédient
magique
le lait de brebis son produit phare le
savent au fond du fleuve mono me
chiffonne mannschaft à une rue des
charmes et cheveux
c'est à dire aux phoques tu laisses
avoue démouler sont mis à sécher durant
quatre semaines
une étape indispensable qui permet à la
saponification de se terminer
les savants de thé halles sont de
petites oeuvres d'art aux vertus
hydratantes et adoucissantes et au
parfum délicieux ces ingrédients 100%
locaux et 100 % bio t as et sa
collaboratrice y met un point d'honneur
et si cléopâtre aimé prendre des bains
au lait d'ânesse
elle aurait sans doute été conquise par
les crèmes de bain au lait de brebis de
thé à la recette du beurre de cacao bio
de l'huile de jojoba et du lait de
brebis aux poudres
quelques herbes aromatiques et d huile
essentielle de rose un peu de miel pour
un bain envoûtant au pays des contes de
fées il n'est pas exclu d'y trouver son
prince charmant
notre groupe de randonneurs a bien
progressé
les voici arrivés au monde à isner
non
couronné par un plateau de 9 kilomètres
carrés le moma isner est le point
culminant de la hesse du nord en
contemplant ce paysage des images tout
droit sortis de l'enfance ressurgissent
quand la forêt s'épaissit nous pensons à
blanche-neige perdu est terrifié et
comme la jeune fille qui découvre le
monde de dames rôle
nous traversons des paysages rayonnant
aujourd'hui la région vit surtout de
l'agriculture et du tourisme
mais il n'en a pas toujours été ainsi
nos pas nous mène vers une ancienne mine
de charbon un témoignage de l'histoire
industrielle dont on peut aujourd'hui
visiter les vestiges
un peu plus loin nous arrivons à
l'apogée de ce voyage les temps de dames
rôle au zoo presque immobile la porte
d'entrée vers son royaume merveilleux
telle une apparition d'un boulot nous
accueille gardiennes des contes et
légendes qui entourent ce lieu mythique
où l'imaginaire prend le pas sur la
réalité
fasciné
nous laissons la magie opérer
dans les légendes et c'hoazh dame rôle
étant tous une vieille dame un peu
effrayante tantôt une jeune fille d'une
exquise beauté qui répand la vie autour
d'elle elle vit au fond de l'étang dans
un monde d'abondance et de sérénité
on dit que de temps en temps elle surgit
des eaux et distribuer les fruits et les
fleurs de son jardin aux enfants qui
osent venir jusqu'à l'entrée de son
royaume
m
certains racontent aussi qu'une nuit un
mineur voulu mesurer la profondeur de
l'étang il approcha de l'eau et lança
son corps d'eau
il boude et vidé la bobine jusqu'au bout
jamais il n'atteint lofo l'étang de
dames rôle est une étape incontournable
de cette balade sous le signe des contes
de fées près de l'étang
nous rencontrons un couple d'éleveurs
monica et mind of steam horberg il élève
des moutons de line une race ancienne de
moutons domestique
aujourd'hui menacé de disparition grâce
au travail et à l'engagement de monica
et de mind of près d'un millier d'hommes
autour de line c'est bakhta nouveau dans
les pâturages de la région
particulièrement adaptée à cette trace
en plus des moutons les tim berg sont à
la tête d'une fratrie de neuf enfants
autant dire que le travail n'a jamais
manqué à la ferme à boire
quand vient la fin de l'été les moutons
regagne la bergerie après avoir brouté
l'herbe fraîche toute la belle saison
ils ont à présent droit aux fourrages
maison bio bien évidemment
et parce que la production bio a besoin
de temps pour fournir le meilleur
les bêtes ne sont pas abattus avant
l'âge de six mois c'est deux fois plus
que dans un élevage traditionnel qualité
coûte l'agneau de monica et l'avion de
prédilection de nombreux restaurants de
la région
aujourd'hui elle effectue une livraison
à berck attal une petite commune au quai
du mont myners elle était attendue par
le chef gerard chine de wolf qui compte
parmi ses meilleurs clients
la chair maigre de l'agneau de line
d'une extrême finesse à coup qui le
restaurateur qui aiment le proposer à
ses hôtes dans de multiples et
savoureuse variations
situé au coeur du village le restaurant
de gerhardt chine de wolf et depuis des
décennies un lieu de rencontre important
pour les habitants qui apprécient la
simplicité et la convivialité du lieu
tout autant que la bonne cuisine du chef
une réputation qui a depuis longtemps
dépassé les frontières de berck attal
toute l'année de nombreux touristes
viennent goûter aux spécialités de
gerhard schick de vol à bord qu'il ya
des malades accord bayh dole pour nous
tenir au courant de cette nature-là
diankha la docteure diane guilbault
craint bonne fin les producteurs et les
gardes et à mes amis avaient
manifestement pas qu'il ya malgré tout
l'auteur de livres en accompagnement de
l'agneau le chef prépare des mails
kindle à la bavaroise de délicieuses
boulettes à base de pain rassis de l'est
et 2 auquel on ajoute des oignons et du
persil
on les cuit dans l'eau bouillante une
dizaine de minutes
une cuisine goûteuse scène avec une
bonne dose de créativité
voilà le credo du chef au menu
aujourd'hui de fines tranches de gigot
d'agneau avec des mails claudel des
légumes frais lui tout agrémenté d'un
concassée de tomates
assaisonner die le restaurant de
gerhardt chine de wolf est une adresse
gastronomique que les touristes
découvrent souvent par hasard mais
l'atmosphère du lieu est sympathique et
la carte prometteuse on y vient pour
prendre un verre et on finit par y
rester dîner
vers la fin de l'après midi
nous reprenons notre route en direction
du sud
le moma senneurs est désormais derrière
nous le soleil bas se fraie un chemin à
travers les feuillages nimbant la forêt
d'une lumière mystérieuse presque irréel
un étrange mobile semble flotter dans
l'air serions nous ensorceler non les
faits ne sont pas en train de nous jouer
un tour nous voici au coeur du projet
art nature à l'art au fil d'une
randonnée initiée sur plusieurs sentiers
de la région des oeuvres d'art 250 au
total nous surprennent au détour d'une
clairière à la croisée des chemins
entretenant avec la nature un dialogue
harmonieux et serein
nous arrivons à proximité de zones tra
dans la petite localité de gran d'une
borne au bord d'un étang le times of
n'attend plus que nos randonneurs
affamés mais attention ce restaurant est
bien plus qu'une jolie auberge
pittoresques ses murs abritent de
véritables merveilles des milliers de
saucisses de toutes les tailles et de
toutes les formes mûrissent paisiblement
mais pas n'importe quel saucisses regin
à edgar line cause les propriétaires du
restaurant fabrique de la halle wurst le
fleuron de la hesse du nord
ils sont membres de l'association des
amis de la halle wurst et n'ont de cesse
de perfectionner la recette pour que
cette spécialité et c'hoazh reste
vivante et actuelle leur travail et leur
engagement leur ont valu de nombreuses
récompenses et la reconnaissance de
leurs pairs
mais qu'est ce qui fait la particularité
de cette saucisse
absolument
amazon pour edgar line rose
une chose est sûre l'origine des
ingrédients détermine tout autant la
qualité de sa charcuterie fine qu'ils se
font d'eux assuré qu'il n'y avait pas
alors que l'article de la recoudre
le tight roof est une entreprise
familiale dont l'histoire remonte à près
de 90 ans
avec l'aide de sa fille regin aline aux
a décidé de gâter notre groupe de
randonneurs
une assiette de charcuterie dont la
simple vue met déjà l'eau à la bouche
suivi d'un assortiment de viandes
servies sur un lit de choucroute
accompagné de pommes de terre
bon appétit
après ce succulent repas
nous abordons la dernière étape de cette
balade
7 je
nous voici arrivés à bright à eau un
charmant petit village de 400 âmes niché
au creux d'une vallée verdoyante
notre groupe de randonneurs a décidé de
faire une halte dans un hôtel pas comme
les autres ils vont s'offrir une nuit
dans un hôtel littéralement un hôtel de
foin un mode d'hébergement d'une
simplicité étonnante on propose aux
clients de dormir sur de la paille
le propriétaire aloïs brugmann en même
ses hôtes dans leur appartement ou
plutôt au grenier le dortoir peut
accueillir jusqu'à 20 personnes
dormir tous ensemble dans la bonne odeur
de foie frais un rêve d'enfant ont juste
un mauvais moment amené à fermer nos
randonneurs eux découvrent le moelleux
des couchages fermiers d'autrefois et
ils semblent apprécier
il faut dire qu'ils ont quelques
kilomètres derrière eux
m
mais au petit matin réveil en fanfare
aloïs burgman a invité tout le village à
la fête du sureau qu'il organise tous
les ans dans le jardin de l'hôtel
c'est l'occasion de découvrir et la
délicieuse productions maison jus de
sureau confiture de sureau schnaps
dessureault on ne compte plus les
possibilités qu'offre cette plante
véritables trésors de la nature d'homme
rôle l'avait bien compris dans son
royaume quiconque veut cueillir le
sureau doit d'abord lui demander la
permission
haykel épouse d'aloïs brugmann est aux
fourneaux
quand il fait beau elle aime cuisiner
dehors dans sa petite cuisine d'été
aujourd'hui elle confectionne un
savoureux chutney avec les baies de
sureau dujardin dans une casserole les
baies de sureau sont mélangés à du sucre
roux des oignons et différentes épices
le tout doit cuire très lentement mais
après deux heures trente le cycle
le tchèque n'est de baies de sureau est
servi en accompagnement d'un rôti de
boeuf bien saignant la vie est douce
dans le jardin d'accueil aloïs un soleil
radieux une mandoline qui égrène ses
notes cristallines une table qui déborde
de victuailles toutes plus alléchantes
les unes que les autres
nos amis n'ont qu'une envie suspendre le
temps et faire durer l'instant
notre histoire se termine à chaque run
stand au beau milieu de la place du
village se dresse un tilleul millénaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle ainsi à la danse
est utilisée à l'origine par les cordier
qui équipaient ces arbres de plateformes
et de charpente ces temples de verdure
sont devenus au fil du temps des lieux
festifs où l'on pris l'habitude de se
retrouver pour danser
aujourd'hui on vient y prendre le frais
à l'ombre des feuillages on s'y raconte
des histoires d'un autre temps des
histoires au personnage étrange et
féerique comme ceux qui peuplent le pays
de dames rôle pour nos randonneurs le
voyage s'achève et après tant de
découvertes de nature et aussi de bonne
chère c'est enfin l'occasion de vérifier
les vertus du biterre dussault ligne
alors santé et à la prochaine
on